Luffy's bounty will surpass Roger at the end
of the story and I will prove it to you with
math.
I've always found bounties pretty irrelevant
in one piece, until recently, when I suddenly
changed my mind about them.
Bounties actually serve a number of purposes
in the story, it's just that I really hate
80% of the toxic power-scaling among fans.
And a lot of them bring up bounties.
So I guess, by default, I got annoyed with
the idea and kind of threw it aside as a nice
little gadget Oda introduced.
However I was watching a really interesting
docu on pirates the other night when I couldn't
sleep, and it sort of hit me that bounties
were a very real and important thing, heck
still are in some places on earth.
I mean I knew that, but having it presented
in that way really had me change my mind.
Hi my name is Manu, my favorite bounty is
the one filled with coconut cream, fuck that's
delicious, and today I'm going to explain
how bounties in One Piece work, my personal
prediction for the straw hats final bounties
and at the end of this video I will show you
how Luffy's bounties have helped to make one
piece great.
A bounty is actually a pretty smart system
in itself.
Here's the deal: Imagine a government that
has a problem on a large scale.
A problem so big and common that the government
alone can't handle it.
So they offer money to anyone who is willing
to help.
So a bounty can be on people or animals or
really anything else.
You can earn money by locating, capturing
or killing.
In one piece, the problem the government is
dealing with are pirates, because all pirates
are evil, and not because they fucked over
the entire world.
Oh but actually it turns out there is also
bounties on revolutionaries.
So in One Piece, whether or not you get a
bounty is not determined by how dangerous
you are to the people, but how dangerous you
are to the rule of the world government itself.
I think a big mistake some people make, not
you I know, but some people, is taking the
bounty system as a system for power scaling.
In other words, the higher a bounty, the stronger
the person.
That's wrong.
Sorry.
Of course power plays a role.
I'm not denying that.
Logically by becoming powerful, you potentially
pose a bigger threat.
And even pirates themselves expect a certain
level of power from someone with a high bounty.
[] However the fact that dragon is the most
wanted man in the world, as I explained in
his analysis video, is because he is a powerful
person actively working to tear down the established
world order.
Not because he's stronger than Kaido or Whitebeard
- probably, right?
Right??
Yeah.
Right?
Similarly, before the time-skip, kid's bounty
was larger than luffy's because he went around
killing and pillaging, unlike Luffy, who's
mostly just hanging out and making friends
wherever he goes.
Oda actually confirmed this in an SBS.
He also noted, that within a crew, the captain's
bounties always increases more than the crew
members' even if the power difference isn't
that big.
There are a few interesting details to the
bounty system.
Obtaining a bounty in the first place, basically
means you are officially a criminal in the
government's eyes.
I think we tend to forget this a bunch, but
these posters actually say dead or alive.
Which is pretty wild, no?
Once you get a bounty, anyone, ANYONE can
come and just shoot you and it's completely
legal.
Which is really fucked up when you think about
examples like little robin, who got her bounty
for being the last survivor of Ohara.
A
little girl with no human rights, if you can
call it human rights what the world government
is pretending to protect.
And of course in just a bit we will look at
Robin's final bounty in the story.
The bounties themselves can be found in bars,
public places and marine buildings.
They serve to warn common citizens of dangerous
criminals, detain these people from entering
a city and at the same time incentivize bounty
hunters, such as Zoro used to be, to go after
these people and earn a living from turning
them in or killing them.
Even though he never discussed it, I'm pretty
sure Oda got inspiration for this system from
his love for western, the bounties on real
world pirates as well as the pictures of wanted
criminals in Japanese police stations.
They remind me a lot of these wanted posters
whenever I see them.
Funnily enough however, even though bounties
are supposed to be something bad and deter
bad people from doing bad things, in the world
of one piece, where the government is as corrupt,
hypocritical and unfair as it gets, pirates
actually take a lot of pride in their bounty.
It serves as a sort of proof of achievement,
where they get their pirate grades at the
end of the year.
While portrayed in a funny way, as you know,
one piece has a very dark sub-tone.
And so for me the fact that there are so many
pirates in this world, forming their own societies
and groups shows us how broken the system
here really is.
Many of the people we meet, only became pirates,
because all over the world people live in
desperation, war and hardship, while the rich
and powerful play god.
Now however, I want to give off my own predictions
for each of the straw hats' final bounties.
-
Luckily, I have a lot I can work with, now
that we finally know some of the biggest bounties
in the story.
The largest bounty so far belongs of course
to the pirate king himself.
That's about 5 million dollars, which is a
lot of money, but enough to risk your life
against one of the strongest people in the
world?
Eaahhh I'd probably pass and go for, like
i dunno 50 buggies or something.
We actually do know the bounty for all the
yonko as well as most of the commanders.
This already gives us a pretty nice range
of where things are heading.
Two bounties I wish I knew for this are that
of dragon and rocks.
How big is the bounty on the head of the most
wanted criminal, who plans to topple the government?
And how much for rocks, the captain of the
most notorious pirate crew?
But let's work with what we get.
*drops cup*
Was the cup empty?
Will my bounty predictions be completely off?
Am I gonna lose all sponsorships because this
transition is so weird?
Find out right after you subscribe you filthy
coward.
But first a word from our sponsor.
A: Jesus, and there they said the rainforests
are dying.
B: Who are you?
A: You know, I know we're in Japan my friend,
but this is taking cultural appropriation
too far.
B: how did you get into my apartment?
- what?
A: I'm salesman Manu, you are live in your
own video right now and I have just the thing
for you.
B: This Video is sponsored by Manscaped.com,
who have sent me their performance package
for Christmas that has you covered from head
to toe, literally.
A: Christmas is already ove-
B: Well international shipping sucks.
Here you go my boy, first things first, the
lawnmower 4.0.
It's a waterproof trimmer, designed for your
sensitive areas with an extra LED so you see
where you go.
Here is our Crop preserver and our Crop reviver,
a game changer deodorant and toner for those
two guys.
Our weedwacker for nose and ear trimming.
*raise eyebrows*
A: *Picking up items* I don't have any nose
or ear hai- *falls silent*
B: And last but not least the Shears 2.0 luxury
6-piece, stainless steel Nail Kit.
And for a limited time you also getting this
travel bag and Manscape's anti-chafing boxer
briefs as gifts, so Go to Manscaped.com and
use my promo code, OHARA, to get 20% OFF plus
free international shipping.
*swipes floor*
Now here are my criteria for my bounties.
Obviously when making predictions like these
you need to make some assumptions.
I'm personally guessing that there will only
be one last big bounty update in the story
overall after Wano.
The straw hats are about to free the land
of the samurai, standing against two Yonko
and they will come out of it as a Yonko crew
themselves.
Everything past the time-skip has lead to
this moment, so of course we need new bounties,
right?
However, other than Roger, who jumped to the
top by finding the one piece and learning
the true history, I don't think Luffy and
co will get another increase after reaching
Laugh tale.
After all, Roger was too early and had to
prepare the next generation.
Luffy meanwhile is the one who will actually
topple the current system and make a world
that is better for everyone to live in.
With the big war at the end of the story,
I don't think there will be time for the government
to make new bounty posters and after that
government won't be there anymore.
The other thing, we will look at are patterns
in the bounties.
And for Luffy his bounties actually are part
of Oda's storytelling.
And part of it will obviously me being bias
and just going the way I feel would make sense.
So first: Chopper.
I think the joke with choppers bounty being
ridiculously low is pretty funny and I want
to see it until the end.
However at the same time he deserves some
recognition.
One way around that would be if chopper got
2 bounties instead of one.
One normal one, super low, and one for his
monster point form, which we could put somewhere
around the 300M mark.
A bounty Luffy once had, but still the lowest
in the crew.
I think all the straw hats will crack the
300M.
Next we have Nami.
As the navigator of the pirate king and increasing
power, Nami will get a solid boost for her
final bounty.
I think putting it up to 400M would be reasonable.
The next spots are a bit trickier, because
everyone gets very powerful from here.
Brook is one of my favorite characters and
I believe he is heavily underestimated in
how dangerous he can be, but I don't see him
going far beyond Nami in terms of bounty.
420 seems a reasonable number.
Hehe.
Now, even though Franky proves to us over
and over again how strong he is, and possibly
still having the plans of the pluton, he is
one of the straw hats who gets very little
recognition from the government.
I'll put him here with around 490M Berry,
more than Sasaki's 472M, but less than our
next candidate: Usopp.
Usopp has gotten a ridiculous 200M berry bounty
after Dressrosa, but as we all know he is
living up to his ideal of becoming a brave
warrior of the sea more and more.
And since he seems to follow round numbers,
similar to luffy, going from 30 to 200, 500M
would be the perfect spot for him after Wano,
more than doubling his current one.
Now we're getting into interesting territory.
I am actually going to put Jinbei in 5th place
here.
He's a former warlord and incredibly strong,
but not quite Zoro, Sanji Luffy material.
However, Jinbe might be very close to the
1B mark.
He went from 76 to 250 to 438, which includes
all numbers, except 1 and 9, so why not 910M
berries.
Ah yes.
Zoro and Sanji.
Even Oda has made fun with the bounties between
the two.
Nonetheless, Zoro's role in the crew is a
bit more centred around combat, while Sanji
is also the cook and in general a much more
personality-based character, I actually made
videos about both recently as well.
I think both will overcome king and queen
and get bounties higher than them.
Being commanders on a new emperor's ship,
both will pass 1B berries, just a little bit
apart.
I'd like Zoro to surpass Luffy's current bounty,
so 1.5B plus 90M for assura's 9 sword style.
Sanji meanwhile I could see somewhere around
the 1.3B mark, plus maybe some 66M for accepting
his germa heritage.
Now, if you've paid attention, you will have
realized that before Luffy, there is still
one straw hat unaccounted for.
I have no idea whether Oda looks at this the
same way as I do, but I personally would love
to see Robin's bounty surpass Zoro and Sanji,
not because of her power, but because of who
she is.
We already know that other Yonko are trying
to steal her for her knowledge, and so is
CP0.
After Wano, once Luffy will shift his eyes
towards Laugh Tale, Robin will be the key
to everything.
The government knows this and will try to
stop it at any cost.
So I would Robin not only to be chased, but
to get the respect for that as well, with
a 2B berry bounty, making her the most wanted
woman in the world after Big Mom's defeat.
Now finally we have Luffy.
And admittedly until now there was not too
much to go off of with the other straw hats.
For Luffy however, bounties have always played
an important role, which makes it easier for
me to predict his final bounty.
For that we have to look at the numbers of
luffs bounty compared to the enemies he has
defeated and how the bounty system keeps pushing
Luffy's unique rise to power into our faces.
Let's start in the east blue.
Luffy's first bounty are 30M Berries after
defeating Buggy (15), Kuro (16), Don Krieg
(17) and Arlong (20).
That's 150% of Arlongs bounty.
And Luffy's bounties will keep outgrowing
his enemies' at this rough rate.
Luffy is presented as the strongest man in
the east blue.
What better way to set him up as the protagonist
and a real threat to the government.
The next increase is in Albasta, that is actually
quite similar to wano.
Both are big Saga's, leading up to a showdown
with one of the most powerful people in this
part of the grand line, crocodile the warlord
and Kaido the yonko, both of whom have bounties
far exceeding Luffy's and seem to be unbeatable
for him at first, Crocodile's logia versus
Kaido's conqueror's Haki.
Before that Luffy faces Mihawk and big mom,
but it's never really about fighting on that
level yet.
After defeating Crocodile, who was frozen
at 81M, luffy triples his bounty to 100M,
over 120% that of his opponent, establishing
himself as someone who can play on the warlord
level, just as he will be able to compete
on the yonko level after wano.
Ennies lobby is a bit different.
Here the bounties are all about the perceived
threat to the world government and not power
in itself.
That's why luffy's enemy has no bounty, while
his own triples to 300M after declaring war
on the government itself.
The next one if maybe the most curious one
though.
After defeating Moria, breaking into and out
of impel down and participating at Marineford,
after all that stuff, Luffy's bounty only
increases to 400M.
You might also have felt like that was too
low, however it wonderfully shows us how Oda
uses bounties to illustrate Luffy's development.
This is Luffy's biggest defeat in the story
so far, not being able to save his crew or
his brother.
It's utter defeat that would have felt weird
to us, the audience, with a ridiculously high
bounty.
Plus, once again it's 125% of Moria's bounty,
who was at 320M.
Dressroas gave Luffy another 100M, bringing
him to 500, 166% that of Caesar's and 150%
of Dofis.
It was a hard fight, but both arcs were only
setup for wano and taking down a yonko.
So taking down another warlord was not as
significant as it was before the timeskip,
even if it was Dofi.
A real curveball in this was then Whole Cake
Island, the last increase so far.
Now, playing on Commander level, luffy surpasses
both cracker and Katakuri, tripling his Bounty
to 150% of Katakuri's 1B.
This ridiculously high new bounty might have
made less sense from the perspective of the
world government, but again as a storytelling
device it does.
Luffy had to surpass himself, facing off against
a version of himself that was better than
him at everything.
It feels deserved to us and to me really hammered
home luffy's achievement on Whole Cake island.
So after all this, the strongest creature
in the world is now standing in front of Luffy
with a bounty fo 4.6B berries, 3 times that
of Luffy just like crocodile.
After defeating an enemy, Luffy has always
surpassed them.
So if we assume that luffy's bounty increases
by 333% like in alabasta, that would round
up very nicely to 5B berries.
However, since we are talking about Luffy's
final bounty in the story, I think he surely
has to surpass Roger.
And Oda loves his wordplays, especially with
the Yonko bounties.
Shanks' bounty has Shanks in it.
Shi-ya-ku.
Kaido has the 100beasts in his.
Hyaku-juu.
Big mom has mom in hers, ha-ha, whitebeard
has Shiro in it, as in white, Shiro hige.
And roger's simply speels ro-ji-ya.
Going with this pattern and the pattern of
Luffy's bounty so far, I'm gonna predict that
Luffy's final bounty will be 5,656,000,000,
go mu go mu, barely surpassing Roger himself.
And speaking of the gomu gomu no mi, if you
want to know what LUffy's awakening might
be and why it is already here, go watch that
video right here.